should think of my chosen in prometheus
he challenged the omnipotence of the God
because like you they might judge jury
and executioner
permit is took away their power the
people closest do always be the most
criticisms you are paying for your
father's who will pay feels Bolivar it's
gonna come for us
yeah I'm counting on it fist I need your
help
NASA's coming back on me hello all of it
welcome back to purgatory
Oliver get coffee chase have across the
plane we can't get off the island
our dis supply ship on the Eastern Shore
the other side of the island
slay knows where it is go now hey hey
Oliver scissors vote on Eastern Shore
you love won't make it in time like my
unconscious moons younger than you are
so are you gonna be fine Lisa I have to
find Williams antha remember because
it's gonna be only with our mom and
felicity
it's just a dream it's real
what happened where you think about man
is
here
it is
wait
we walk in - well we can only do that
for so long
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we're
talking about arrow season 6 this is all
episode 1 footage they didn't start
shooting till a little bit after the
flash season 4 started shooting so they
just don't have as much footage
available but there is a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video there's a whole
lot of stuff to talk about Deathstroke
Richard Dragon Michael Emerson from loss
joining the cast three huge big things
but it goes way beyond that - vigilante
is still a big thing I know you have a
lot of questions about that they
confirmed that they will unmask that
character during the season hey we're
here with you in 2012 when no one had
seen the show and now on our 3rd episode
we'll be a hundred away from passing
Smallville Wow not that I've thought of
like what Michael and Michael Emerson
yeah belong with them much come on Oh
crazy my name is Elle I just assumed it
well I mean I'm gonna hate to kill him I
want to say the crossovers going to be
super cool this year and it's going to
be pulled from a very cool DC story that
the fans are going to know about when
they hear it three muses very excited
but the big thing here is that they
confirmed that you're going to pick up
six months later and then you'll flash
back to explain what happened this night
so that's why you're seeing footage of
the blown-up Island Oliver running
through I love the way they use color in
this too with everything looking all red
and orange and just burnt to hell with
Slade walking through like oh my god
what just happened the only thing I
think they're teasing here is that one
character dies that we did not know died
at the end of last season like we're
pretty sure that Merlyn died because of
what John Barrowman has been saying in
Captain Boomerang died with him but
beyond prometheus there were all these
questions about everybody's standing in
this group here with Slade rewatching
this I forgot that Samantha ran off on
her own to try and find William so I
think that's a bit of a dead giveaway
that she's probably the person who died
so it's gut-wrenching for Oliver it
dramatically changes the dynamic between
him and William but they've already had
this moment where he learned that
Oliver's the Green Arrow he's been
through all this trauma and they said
that Oliver is going to be getting an
apartment during season six this might
be with that apartment
so we'll see how that works out but it
sounds like he might be living with
Oliver on a more permanent basis but as
far as main cast members I'm 99% sure
that pretty much everybody's coming back
they're not going to kill Katie Cassidy
off she shows up fighting Black Canary
so you have black sirens versus Black
Canary this season they did say that
they would tease the idea of a
Redemption for black siren and because
they're bringing Michael Emerson on and
he's actually being listed as Richard
dragon on IMDB but I couldn't find
confirmation of that so we know we're
getting Richard dragon and we know we're
getting Michael Emerson so whatever his
plan is going to be for Oliver this
season it sounds like black siren might
get mixed up with him at least the first
half of the season
you see Deathstroke giving Oliver the
handshake in the hospital here he lived
up to his terms of the agreement he
helped them take down Prometheus and get
everybody off the island so now he has
the information about where to find his
son Joseph
Jericho that's going to consume his arc
for the first part of the season Stephen
Amell was like yeah we're hoping to
bring him back several times but I'm
digging the new Black Canary costume
that Dinah Drake is wearing is a little
more inspired by the new 52 version of
the costume that was also a period when
Dinah Drake was a version of The Black
Canary so it makes sense they would go
in that direction you don't see him in
the trailer but they did confirm that
anatolian the broad bug would be coming
back so beyond that the only other
confirmations we have is that when
Deathstroke does come back it will be a
big two-part episode but as for
vigilante they just said that they would
be unmasked this season and it would
make sense when the mask came off so it
sounds like it's going to be somebody
that we know and I know a lot of people
are like what about McKenna Hall is
jaehnig ankov are going to be vigilante
because she would actually be a pretty
good pick somebody who used to be a cop
maybe they got really pissed off with
what Oliver's been doing the last couple
of seasons and took matters into their
own hands but she was actually just cast
on a different movie so I think it's
less likely but I do really like the
idea of that and I know people really
want Colton Haynes to come back they're
like where's Roy
how come he hasn't come back yet he was
just cast on American Horror Story
so he's busy doing TV on Fox they don't
go off the air without him coming back
at least once and I'm not expecting him
to be vigilante either but otherwise let
me know what you guys really hi
about it seems like it's going to be
really strong seasoned people have been
leaving comments that they confirm that
war world will be the four night
crossover but I haven't seen any
official confirmation of that
so we'll just open up another tab in
chrome for that if they make more
announcements but that would be an easy
way to explain how things start on
Supergirl because she would be the first
night of the crossover before they go on
the other TV shows but really excited
about Michael Emerson he's an awesome
actor can't wait to see what he does
with the character obviously if he's
going to be Richard dragon it'll be a
little bit different from the comics but
leave all your bonus video requests in
the comments below there's still a whole
bunch of Young Justice season 3 that we
need to talk about there's a bunch of
Avengers stuff that they announced like
Captain Marvel versus the scrolls and
it's going to take place in the 90s so
there's just a lot of comic book stuff
to get through but there'll be more Game
of Thrones before the weeks over -
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Jake Franklin please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details so
while you wait for everything you can
click here to learn all about the flash
season 4 and you can click here to watch
the trailer for the next Game of Thrones
episode thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight